well do you want to move on to uh
bullet okay so do you want to first of a
bullet for 15
15 you said yes one five okay first one
first i heard five zero but uh that
would be way too bad
we're not donya like those people can't
do that
yeah i've i get tired after uh after
some amount of games so yes for sure
yeah first to 15 sounds good
okay awesome
okay i'm gonna play this line ah she's
not going into it
okay let's play one of these again
okay we're gonna try and manage time i'm
already down on time
is this some theory i don't think this
is a theory
delayed bond cloud kind of about five
oh good move take okay we're gonna trade
everything
um play this move
maybe trap the knight
i just want her to take my pawn
just take my pawn ah i was waiting for
rook b1 to get the castle fork
but okay that's not happening i like
that in game though
assuming i'm not getting mated
okay hitting the pawn
put the knight somewhere happy
take a pawn
threatening this to win the bishop
no that was a blunder
should still be good winning chances
no why do i keep plundering things
let's go okay
that was such bad uh some bad pre-moving
on my part
oh wow she was so close to coming back
there
okay that's a wake-up call let's play
let's play this garbage opening
ah she's not falling for it okay
um yeah so i'm down upon
this is a reverse england gabbat
let's just go for meat
i'll play this
turning a pawn so what i want to do is
play
g3 king g2 and then rook h1
um can win the queen
like i have g5 if here i take because
there's a pin
and now i have the h file this is
looking really good
and we're going to create the gone along
each file
my king will briefly experience outside
[Music]
world
not quite meeting
threatening meat
okay unpinning there we go
okay let's go okay that's some
interesting game so far
okay so that's two i guess we'll have to
keep track because i started with 10.5
um yeah we'll play another one of these
i wanna i want her to take but she's not
taking so maybe i'll play this
or what is this
g5 okay
so i've expanded with the pawns on both
sides
trying to be sneaky with my queen i
probably just want to keep pushing
pawns
interesting
i really want to take but it's not good
let's play this
this pawn is hanging but these pawns are
hanging all the pawns are hanging
yeah good move
this might be slightly painful
i'm down on time we need three maybe
oh my knight but
oh maybe this move
not a good position oh there goes
white's bishop
okay very dirty flag there i've been
trying to give spy checks
that's the nature of bullets that's a
cool game though
um let's play this and go for the
intercontinental
missile whatever we call this
i don't know if it's good but it looks
fun so this is like one
one of the lines right made this move
trying to trap the bishop i have to
watch out for this
mating idea
um i guess i can take here first
hitting the rook
very confusing position
okay let's win this thing
check
here we go
okay that worked out really well
up the exchange and
i guess pawns are black has a pawn for
it
so i want to get rid of this pawn plans
to play 94 rook c1 and take
okay close to meet
that was a bad move
i'm freezing
here we go
let's go yeah i was having a hard time
moving fast like there was some lag
but okay got the job done let's go
okay uh what to play
let's play this dubious move let's play
f5 i don't know what i'm doing but it
looks fun
reverse king's gambit
okay can't complain
oh almost trapping the bishop let's
start with this
and then attack the pawn from afar
go for this move okay attacking two
pawns
and i want to bring the queen in
as a mate threat it's almost made
threats
oh no my bishop
oh good move i can take and
oh no my rook i just want her to take my
pieces
uh wait what do i do
play this move
okay now i'm going in for the kill and
the queen's tied down to the bishop so
if here i take and take
this should be working somehow it's
knight a2
and then this and okay
oh she resigns oh it was a fork oh it's
a triple fork
okay okay that was nice
did that answer your question i
[Music]
i don't know thanks for your feedback
what okay um
yeah the robots are always listening
at least i got a refresher on my
multiplication tables
okay um
let's move
oh why do i waste a tempo because uh to
play the england gambit
because she doesn't play d4 as white but
um she plays d5 against e3
so it's a way to try and get like just a
fun gambit
okay so i think i'm winning wait
is there a puzzle rush here
f2 i play this move first
okay that was nice okay
focus um
[Music]
i just want her to take oh bishop dk
i i tell i i used to teach like young
kids and told them not to do this
it's a pointless bishop oh but she's
kind of making it work
what
because the bishop like blocks upon
which blocks other bishop which blocks
her rook but
i guess she kind of made it work like
we're transposing into
[Music]
an italian or spanish
do i go insane i could take
i kind of want to take
and then if takes i get the g file
this shouldn't work but it might work
i'll start with this
i don't know what i'm threatening
i guess f2 is hanging
oh that worked out nice oh she was
expecting knight takes she wasn't
expecting bishop takes
so she she made the wrong pre-move there
okay
okay um how many games is that
i guess i've i've won all the one minute
game so far
okay we'll play a black mardemour
or a ride the rider gamut take my pawn
ah play this move
okay so this is like a fun kind of weird
gambit i'm down the pawn
but uh there's a lot of potential to
attack
g4 g5
yeah my king will be oops
will be weirdly placed in the center
of this move threatening mate
i have six i take and then still
threaten meat
if i only i could unpoissant with a
bishop that would still be bad though
so i can take
yeah that's not what i was hoping for
it's still playable though
fighting mates
just put my king on each one
setting up for the next game
oh good move this move
okay threatening rookie 6
again threatening rookie 6
or queen h6
what is this what's going on
don't hurt me
no i'm losing
ah i was trying to sell the stalemates
with brook takes
eight three stalemate but i was the
tempo too short
okay that's the first lost in bullets
good game
life goes on
i'm trying to trick her into a stafford
i'll play
this and then this
okay we'll have a reverse maybe a black
lion
oh i could play uh there's a cool line
in this move if not here
never mind
oh is there a prediction i see the
prediction result is no
whatever that means sorry people who
believed in me maybe
okay but life goes on so let's
let's try and be aggressive still
um probably takes his best and
yeah maybe i'll push f5 the threat is f5
f4
okay we're just going to keep pushing
pawns push all the pawns
i'll just keep pushing pawns until i
can't push pawns anymore
upon all the pawn okay now i have to
move the knight
um
castle never too late to castle opening
principles
die i got forked okay i'm gonna set up a
sneaky trick
oh good move wait how does this move
it's getting weird this whole game is
what is a
structure pawn structure is bananas
okay she had queen c2 i think
what is this
this is so confusing
okay oh i won on time let's go okay
what's that game oh man okay
um let's play this and this
and then this yeah this is uh i show the
mon hamilton this
this is xqc variation xqc like randomly
did this when he was a beginner
it's actually a cool line uh let's play
this move
so i just want a pawn um because the
center was hard to defend
play this move
ooh i take a
let's just go insane delayed polish i
still have to play a real polish
okay so i'm still up upon have the b
file move the queen back defending
pressuring this
good move
i'm opening the the fourth rank okay
we're going to save the bishop
so i want to play this hitting the night
just kind of stuck
this move
some idea of maybe taking maybe this
move
i think she missed the discovery there
going after this pawn
scary position i don't know what to do
there goes my pieces
oops oops oops oops
ah i got uh
i was queenie2 was not intentional but
oh what to do i'll play this very it's a
bad variation
um don't try this at home there's like
one trap that she didn't fall for
um let's play this hitting both oh maybe
she fell for
what is this takes
i'm disobeying like all the opening
principles
oh but i'm preventing white from
castling which is kind of cool
uh a castling queen side is coming can
try and trap the bishop
she's fighting me with that
oh it's a it's a thing and it's gonna be
another thing
oh but that's also a thing okay so i can
say castle too
what is this game
i guess we're just getting um
close equal position
okay wow
exotic pawn structure she probably
should have taken that
but i'm winning a pawn
this meeting it's almost mating rook c3
is an oh no never mind
it's very close to mating
oh her king is slippery
it's still winning i think better be
and she played that well i'm losing uh
objectively but it's probably going to
be a flag
try okay
okay so that's nine wins
nine wins for me two wins for her in the
bowl portion
let's go one more game maybe
okay
i'll try and make this the last game
let's play um oh i forgot to play the
polish
delayed polish
uh i was trying to show love for her
country
or one of her countries um
okay
i kept forgetting let's un
do the knight this is very hippo like
are there hippos in poland
probably at the zoo
okay or hedgehog like
okay very solid position ooh
[Music]
can i play f3
f3 winning connect four and maybe
winning a rook
and maybe winning a queen okay
she could have played on like the takes
takes but um
yeah it's still better for whites yeah
queen for two minor pieces
okay i think that's
is that the match i think that's it oh
the prediction's still going
uh there's a way to just abort the
prediction
and refund the channel points i think
um maybe
those are some fun oh first of 15. oh uh
first of 15 i forgot my bad
uh yeah she we had this whole thing like
between one five and five
zero for some reason i was thinking
first to ten
okay i have to get back in game mode
ooh it's a fork
okay some nice opening trap it's a
danger of pre-moving in the opening
the thing is she's getting a time
advantage almost every game
except this game
okay let's castle queen side and we're
gonna go for the the quick attack
put all the pieces on the king's side
save the bishop maybe play f5
oh
clocks were flashing for a moment there
wait what i just lose a piece i just
lost a piece
okay i'm gonna pretend like it's all
part of the plan
g3 the power of g3 is the f1 can't take
because there's a pin the thing is a g
pawn's defended
let's start by taking the trade queens
now
yeah kind of weird game so far we've
both made blunders
i want to go for the smothered mates
not gonna happen but maybe
but maybe not
plenty of time
okay okay
move quickly enough there play one of
these oh no i went
okay i have to play a pole okay i'll
play a wing gambit whatever this is
meets the polish um
am i supposed to do this
i don't know the proper way to play so
i'll just throw pawns yeah i'll throw
all the pawns
pawns are such fun objects to throw
defend the thing oh it's kind of a fork
okay hitting the knight
um
it's almost a center pawn cube
let's attack the bishop first
and fork i can't queenside castle
uh let's play what's this position
in the fake queenside castle
except i can't oh no don't
perpet me oh she's winning my rook
oops all hail the porn cube oh yeah all
hail
bow down okay maybe this move
hey let's go i win the rook
if you encounter the queen
bishop d3 and rook g1
save pre-move play this and this
there we go
threading this or that
my time what
no
no i didn't realize my time was so low
oh no
no okay
[Music]
ah let's play
keep playing these random openings
aha okay i don't mind this
actually like this position
yeah gonna go for the quick attack as
usual
yolo good move though oh my queen's
almost trapped
okay i really have to do better with
time this game
compared to that last game
no i meant to castle okay
oh i'm getting pinned well played there
might lose this one uh
oh or i might win this one
is she quick enough with the pawns not
quite
barely
it's still a fight though let's make a
pass pawn
okay here we go plenty of time
okay that was a weird game she
completely outplayed me and then got
forked
okay polish time polish let's go been
meaning to play this every game
um play b5 and then we'll combine it
with a grub
uh that's an interesting move
like this
the polish meets the grub grop isn't
really a country
but it's still kind of a what is it
[Music]
identity
okay i'm gonna play b6 and get the weird
queen bishop battery
i want to go for like knight free pawn
i guess we could trade pawns
yeah let's trade pawns
threatening mate queen b1 then this move
oh i'm not winning just yet
it's close to winning though f6 or that
move
so i want to take and then mate tricky
tricky
it's actually kind of annoying my time
is low again
okay i like the position still but it's
going to take some work
make a outpost on g7 maybe ooh
what just happened there oh my thing
okay but her thing
is this
no
my time
it's so sad
ah i was pre-moving somewhat there
okay and she's so fast and strong
especially
with material
uh what do i play here
i'm going to play a normal let's play um
a schliemann
which is actually more normal compared
to what i've been playing
and then this and then this
okay every game she's queenside castling
so we're getting a lot of kind of sharp
positions
okay going for the meat what
okay i'm just becoming more blind
missing too many things here
uh let's try and survive though it's
casually giving queen odds
good move
please take my pawn she sees it though
there we go that's all i needed
ah i was lagging ah
and she yeah she was just quicker too
oh good game that was really close
okay what's the score oh
12 to five okay let's play something
normal
let's just play london normal
average london i'm gonna play mainline
been doing too many crazy things
go for this line
okay this this makes me happy winning a
pawn now
okay
oh
uh i think this is good
complicated okay this is looking much
better now
play this the king up
now let's make next move unless she
takes
oh she could take wow i can't take back
i have to play this
okay it should still be winning that was
a weird sequence
oh she's fast though
i'm going to try and be fast too
oh it's a was a draw there but now it's
winning
okay let's go
okay let's go back to something normal
uh maybe d5
just got a happy position
oh i know what i wanted to play i want
to play an alakan
um oh but if i win two more the match is
over right
i think
i have to look back on the stats like
how many games has she castled queenside
so i feel like it's over 50 oh this
there's this move or that move
um let's hunker down
it's kind of painful
okay staying alive i want to play a3
it's a nice kind of undermining move
oh that was smart
okay so we're trading everything so i'm
not getting mated then game's worse for
me but
uh i have a small time advantage
oh wow oh that's okay i have to play
this
now it's not even worse for me
okay uno mas let's go e4
we're gonna play grand prix attack time
i'll put the queen maybe on h3
yeah got a nice kind of
bind on the king side
uh it's looking really really nice
this move
i need time i can go for f6 right now oh
my queen
oops oops oh but the rook
wait it's not over
yeah that's such a nice attacking
build-up too
okay it's not bad though i have material
for it for whatever i lost
i'm almost trapping the black queen
what is this oh no you're queen oh no my
queen
my time okay
i want to open the diet yeah this
diagonal
okay that's a nifty move
the bishop's almost trapped
to do this maybe this this move i don't
know
such a weird position
okay so i'm attacking the queen and the
rook
making use of that pin
how does she keep escaping
there's another pin
no i flagged wow
she was so fast with the king my pieces
were all around and then she took them
that's kind of sad okay one more one
more i'm gonna play an alekhine
um was there a prediction going
and a lot of people lost channel points
but maybe some people gain channel
points
okay so alkyne time
um wait what is this
c4 i'll play knight b4 and then
takes this way yeah okay that's what i
wanted
some quick opening trap here we go
uh let's take a rook but it's never over
till it's over
have this move oh that's not legal
that's not illegal okay let's um let's
play a legal move
castle yeah there goes my knight
maybe not
[Music]
nice finish okay
my night survived i was not expecting
that
okay i want a game to finish things f5
mate
on move 16.
okay yeah king here i would uh i would
win the queen
oh hello hello yeah i can't believe the
last game ended with my king in the
middle of the board
yeah that was unexpected i was so kind
of sad i was gonna lose my knight on a1
but it survived
yeah my king just this was literally i
play like sir dash dude
did you see this yeah i did not put
okay yeah so oh my god
ah i can't believe i can't end up in the
middle of the board but so that was a
really really good match gg
it was fun yeah um it was some
uh some really hard fought games you uh
you moved really quickly that second to
last game where
i was checking your king all around i
thought i was gonna slow you down but
you just kept taking my pieces
and pre-moving everything was crazy
the flagging is getting better i'm
getting better at flagging for sure
yeah i i feel like you you outperformed
me and like the kind of pre-moving but
a lot of the time scrambles i i was
happy to have like some
additional time saved up so
i honestly think that those games were
really interesting i felt like this
match was really close which is
awesome because i don't remember what
the score for last match was but i think
this one this time it definitely went
better you know
you you definitely improved on uh on the
previous match
um have you been have you been really
like working on your chest recently
yes i actually have i actually have i
want to go for international master
oh that's awesome yeah so that's why i
have been trying a little bit harder
do you have any uh any i am norms i have
one
oh okay if you have one then then it's
like more motivating
for sure i like i mean i mean like i i
my highest rating was 23.67
okay so it wasn't like super far off
of course it was so far off but like i
think i could do it if i
just like try you know yeah and this is
a one of the best times to study
like given that there's not so many over
the word norm tournaments happening
you can really um devote more time to
study and then come back and try and uh
try and have some good performances
exactly
yeah a lot of people ask me if i'm going
for the gm title but i have no gm norms
my
my rating dipped since i got the im
titles so
well so does mine but it's okay you know
so
something that one of my friends told me
the other day is you don't need to set
goals for yourself
but just consider what you're happy
about and i just decided that i'm not
happy with where i am in chess i don't
necessarily want to get the
international master
title and i'm like it's kind of a goal
but also i
just i just want to like improve my
chess so that's why
yeah i think it's it's much more
effective
and it's just um a better approach to
focus on the journey
rather than the final destination and
just enjoy kind of learning process
and improving and like learning from
your wins and your losses
and exactly it just makes everything
more enjoyable so
that's my goal these days too is just to
have have fun and and try and keep
getting better and
maybe if i get like a gm norm then i'll
be more motivated to get the time
but that's not not exactly okay you're
happy with where you are i think that's
the most important part
definitely definitely yeah well thank
you so much for the match today that was
a lot of fun it was also very exhausting
oh my god
it's tiring playing like so many games
back to back and then going from like
blitz to bullets
and uh yeah no not too many breaks
so it was fun though i i think uh i i
hope people
from both chats enjoyed it and maybe
learned a thing or two
same same